okay
we'll go ahead and get started my name
is angela mcdonald i'm one of the career
coaches at udacity
recently we had another we had a
fireside chat
style conversation webinar and this is a
follow-up to that if you didn't get a
chance to attend that or watch it
recorded you can definitely do that
later and
this will all make sense even without
having attended
so i'm going to go ahead and share my
screen and we'll get started
all right again this is about all about
returning to work
after a career break and we're going to
revisit the relaunch
uh that was the name of our session we
had last time so today's
agenda we're going to recap that
fireside chat talk about what we learned
we're going to look at building career
confidence getting that confidence back
when you're ready to go to
back to work especially if it has been a
bit of a break
and we'll look at how you discuss your
gap and some do's and don'ts about
that discussion
so on july 30th we had a fireside chat
with carol fishman cohen she's the count
chair and co-founder of a company called
i relaunch
which is a pioneer company in the career
re-entry space
essentially they started out by going to
companies and helping them
set up what almost is like an internship
but they call return ships and they have
similar names where it in the beginning
it was all about helping
women come back to the come back to work
after
maybe staying home with their kids for a
while that was
the start of it it's really expanded to
be so much more
people who have taken gaps in their
career to maybe have
explored a hobby or a side business
family leave
medical leave even military breaks
whatever the case may be when you've had
an extended break
coming back has its challenges and
they've done a lot of help with that
part of it is they've co-founded and
co-lead the stem re-entry task force
with the society of women engineers
the link is there and i can post that in
the chat and a little bit or
maybe one of my colleagues can post that
in the chat so that you can see it
if you would like to watch that at a
later time
all of our webinars are always posted on
our youtube page so you can go there
anytime and see
the different sessions we've had
so these are some things we learned
we'll kind of recap these for you
so one of the first things carol talked
about was documenting your experience
and milestones in your career
so if you're listening to this now and
you have a plan for maybe taking a break
or a plan in five years or a year or
maybe you're right
in your break now start document that
experience the sooner the better if
you've done it all along that's
fantastic
think about those big milestones some of
the big achievements that you've had
look through your resume and think about
extracting
the different experiences projects
and work you've been involved in that
best highlights
you and your strengths and if you keep
that documentation all along it makes it
a lot easier
when you're getting ready to go back to
work to start pulling from those
examples and remembering those stories
so it's not too late to start
documenting some of us may have to go
back a little further in our history and
and think about those and and remember
some of those situations
those of you who are new in your career
and think about a
future break then this is a great thing
to keep track of now
the next thing we talked about is how
much relationships
matter and that could be you know when
you think about the workplace that you
have people of course your peers you've
got people above you you've got people
under you when you get ready to re-enter
the workspace
it's really important to reach out to
all of those connections
it's very possible that someone maybe
that you work for
at one company is now at your dream
company and that's someone you want to
reach out to
your peers might have moved up in the
juniors as well
to be at a place where they can hire you
you might go back and work for someone
who used to work for you
and i think that part of that is
keeping those relationships and thinking
about that all relationships matter
and also it's important to know that if
you have taken especially an extended
break
you might come back in a position that
is a little bit lower than maybe someone
who
who was with you at the time and they've
they've kind of stayed in the career and
moved up
it might take some time to work your way
back up and and letting go a little bit
of that
that ego or that title that you feel
like you should have
and know that sometimes that first step
back in
may not be that ideal place that you
want to be
but it will it will get there it'll get
there and we'll talk about a lot of
techniques and things you can do
to make sure you're taking those steps
in your career
the next is to let people know that
you're on the market
really let people know you're looking
for a job it's amazing how many people i
talk to every day
and they they're very isolated in the
job search and it's something very
normal that happens to people
and especially in the current situation
where many of us are
either working remote or if we're
unemployed and still at home
whatever the situation may be most of us
are pretty isolated already
physically so it's important that we
reach out and talk to people phone calls
zoom calls
emails texts and let people know we're
looking for a job
people very close to us it might be a
conversation of
hey can we chat let's have a glass of
wine on the phone tomorrow night and
i want to tell you about something so
that might be a way you approach it with
someone you're really close to
now there might be someone you worked
with a long time ago you need to kind of
rekindle that relationship so it might
be
a little more of a formal email reaching
out and saying hey i'd love to talk to
you about
how things are going with you would you
have time for a chat and arrange
something more
more professionally whatever the way you
can approach people
to just let people know you're available
let them know you're looking for a job
so many times people hold that in they
feel embarrassed
they feel scared they feel like they
don't want to talk about it
and jobs are found on
the sidelines of people watching their
kids sporting events
if people find out about opportunities
at family reunions
talking to a friend who knows someone
else that mentions your name
we all know that that a lot of that
organic job search kind of that hidden
market
opportunities um we'll never find those
if we don't let people know we're
available
the next item is finding strategic
volunteer opportunities and volunteer
gigs
and this is really a great way to if
you're getting ready to take a break or
maybe you're at the end of your break
and you're trying to find ways to kind
of get back
into things finding ways to volunteer
where you can use some of your
professional skills
so if i am a
let's say i'm a digital marketer and i'm
hoping to go back to work and but i'm
going to take a couple years off
what i might do is is try to keep you
know keep my feet in the water a little
bit
and see if i can get some opportunities
to do some digital marketing small
projects they could be through a
non-profit
they could be for a small business there
are several websites that you can look
at
and we'll give those to you later
there's a creative fire
and volunteer match where you can find
opportunities to use your very specific
skills
so that you're keeping up to date uh
lean in if you will
uh say that um so that you're you're
using those skills you're
you're showing that pro like that you
are seeing in the game a little bit
and using those whether you do it all
along
or you kind of catch up there at the end
of your break
either way is great and last is to be a
fearless learner
carol talked a lot about being a
fearless learner as they hire people
coming back from breaks they know people
will be rusty
in certain areas maybe in some of the
technology
and maybe a new platform whatever it is
just showing your enthusiasm
and your interest in learning and
wanting to catch up
i always you know like to say that
anytime you're new on a job
those first three months the first six
months you're going to spend a lot of
time
figuring things out getting up to speed
and getting up that learning curve in
the job
and that is completely normal and then
things taper off and can usually get to
a bit normal pace
and if you've taken a few years off of
work or many years off of work
that that fearless learning that
learning curve in those first few months
will feel even a lot steeper but it's
that determination
and the attitude that you take to
approach it that can
employers are really going to value and
you're going to feel yourself
really up to speed and on track in no
time
what else did we learn we learned that
companies see value in mature employees
many people who have taken long breaks
are a little more mature
they've seen that people that are more
mature have a lot of great experiences
to pull from
professionally personally they we
we get a lot better with managing our
time and our responsibilities as we
mature in our careers
another great thing is that many other
people have relaunched successfully and
they've paved the way for people
like you that have taken a break so
you know if we were having this
conversation 15 years ago it'd be very
different
it was really hard for people to come
back after a career bake they felt like
they had to go get a masters or a phd or
do something
really big and make a big investment to
get back to work
um the next is many large companies now
have created formal
paid relaunch programs these can look
very different and we'll give you some
resources to look into some of those
and learn about more of those if you uh
are interested in qualified
some are very formal they look for
people with very specific criteria
specific skills
others are a little more broad and don't
have maybe
such specific criteria so you can look
through and see if there's one that
looks right for you
and essentially they a lot of them are
like internships where you rotate around
the company or a couple different
departments
to see where you might fit in so you get
that upskilling
you get back in the groove of getting
back to work
and then figure out where it is you're
best placed
and the last thing we learned is it's
never too late to relaunch carol talked
about people who
made major career changes took huge
breaks
10 15 years even and got back to work
and it's important to remember the gaps
happen i know a lot of people really
feel nervous about their gap for
whatever the reason they
if they stayed home to care for their
children or other family members
they just took a sabbatical for health
or for fun
they lost their job unfortunately a lot
of that happening right now and to know
that
it does happen to a lot of people you're
not alone and most of the time it's
not uh it's not as negatively
it doesn't look as negatively on you as
maybe people felt like it had
in the past maybe you endured a long
medical leave or you took time off to
study so whatever the reason is that
you've had a gap know that you're not
alone
and that there are ways to come back
and we're going to help you find some of
those ways and look at different
strategies
so i'd like to know you know as we kind
of think about it right now
what it is that
you feel like are you what concerns you
most about your gap and you can just
chat that in
the chat bar i'm going to stop sharing
for just a second so i can see the chat
pop up there we go
and see what maybe some of the questions
that have come up
as well so you can let me know in the
chat and you can
if you don't want to share with everyone
that's okay you can chat privately
and just let me know what concerns you
most if you've had a career break what
is your biggest concern
and i'm going to answer one of the
questions that's in the chat now while
i'm waiting to see some of your
chats come through
i see that yvonne one of other career
coaches is on thank you ivan she shared
the youtube link to the fireside chat
and she also has provided us with those
links for the
volunteering so thank you for that then
we have a question from
chris when learning new skills like
taking a udacity course when
is it appropriate to update linkedin the
beginning after completing
after getting some post-class experience
i think it's great to put it's just
i like to think of it as going to
university you put your university on
the
sometimes the day you get accepted right
or the day you start
i think that's okay as long as you're
open and transparent about when you're
finishing so you might put on there
i'm taking udacity computer vision
expected completion
you know october 2020. and
if some people i know are sometimes they
get a nervous about like oh will i
finish am i really going to be
successful should i put it on or not if
you're not sure if you have a little
insecurity there it's also okay to wait
i think by the time you've completed it
then heck yeah you should get it on
there
i recommend putting it in your education
section for sure
because that's where most recruiters
will look
for those skills experience and
but keeping the content under it brief
so you don't
especially if you've taken a lot of
different courses and you don't want to
muddy that education section
with just listing every single thing
that you did in that class
you can talk more about the details and
the projects
in different places and then the
certificates when you finish you'll get
the certificate and you can post that
in the certificate section on linkedin
so i hope that helps chris and then doug
asks i recently had
a heart and kidney transplant wow i'm so
glad you're here and congratulations for
um
getting through that and being here and
i think that's fantastic so
i know that seeing that you're taking a
long medical stability
sabbatical for your recovery and i hope
that's all going well and you're staying
safe doug and you know as you i'm
guessing you're taking some udacity
classes and that's how you're here
i think that's one of the best things
you can do is is to keep
keep your brain working right you've got
physically you've got a lot of
uh healing to do and to take care of
and you know if you can keep yourself
technically in the space where you want
to be i think will help
give you something to to look forward to
and to work on and and to push yourself
in in different ways but
um and maybe it's it's a it's also a
great time as you're as you are
recovering to think about what it is you
want to do next
thinking about how to position yourself
getting everything ready that the future
job search might hold updating your
resume
having your linkedin prepared there's a
lot of things you can do without
even thinking about applying for a job
yet but getting all those
other pieces in place and as you go
through the udacity career portal
and have some coaching sessions we can
help lead you through
what it is to do at each step
the doug followed up with i may take
more time as i reboot my career
to stop being a manager and going back
to being a programmer or consultant
until i retire maybe
and maybe a decade i think that's great
you know and i think
that as long as whatever you go back to
do is
suitable to you and you're happy
that is what matters and feeling like oh
i was a manager and
i'm coming back at something else
doesn't mean there's
you know there's nothing wrong with that
and i know actually a lot of people in
tech who
have found themselves getting into a
management role and they're like oh wait
a second i kind of like that
individual contributor being in the one
doing the coding and
that piece of it so i think that's a
good idea to to
go back and maybe have less managerial
responsibilities
and then you know you can always
see where else you would like to be next
and that could obviously change over
time as well
wonderful thank you all for sharing
we're going to go back to our
presentation here
so how do we build up that career
confidence and you know and
and some of this doug might be things
you can be thinking about over time
because you're not looking right now but
one of the most important and this is
where i feel like all of udacity
students
are on top of this piece is being
relevant and updating your knowledge in
the field and that goes back to that
fearless learning that carol talked
about to show
hey like even if i've taken a break or
i'm in the middle of a break i'm going
to continue
keeping my skills fresh taking classes
working on projects doing programming
exercises
and and even you know if you are at home
and you're not ready to go back full
time
finding little projects or side gigs can
also be really
effective in keeping your skills up and
maybe even some of that
having a little side money as a bonus
the next is to network and get
professionally connected with people
again i you know i talked about
letting people know you're looking
really thinking about your network who's
in it
who can help you maybe there's been
someone you've helped in the past and
they're a great person to reach out to
next
even just having conversations to know
that you're connected and
in the conversation of the field that
you're in can
really really help and
building confidence and knowing your
pitch and addressing the gap and that's
what we're going to talk about
when we talk about knowing your pitch
and your elevator pitch and your
introduction we've done a few different
webinars on that that you can find
in our youtube channel but today we're
going to talk about addressing the gap
because a lot of times i think that's
where people feel really scared and
stuck in an interview
how do i describe it how do i talk about
it and it's like this black cloud that
just feels like it's hovering and
waiting you down
as you are going into an interview or a
conversation
and it doesn't need to be that way
so first how do we stay relevant
following industry blogs and these are
like a lot of these things
all of these things actually as we look
down the list are all things you can do
while you're on your break
and obviously if you're taking your fun
sabbatical if you're
busy taking care of someone there might
be days that go by where you can't do
all of many of these things
but keeping it as one of your priorities
that you can get around to maybe setting
a day of
you know if it's a time of day or a few
days a week
to follow industry blogs to read
industry news
making sure if you follow top companies
on linkedin and follow those
influencers in your field so you're
seeing that feed and you're reading that
information and you're not feeling
too disconnected from where it is that
you work
obviously educating yourself on any new
office technology that might have come
around by
since you were last in in the in the
office
and lastly joining related groups on
linkedin
if you're not sure which groups to find
sometimes you can just search by some
keywords
in your field you can also look at other
people
maybe some of your peers people you know
that do a similar job
um doesn't even have to be someone you
know could be other people with your
same title
and see which groups they're on see who
they follow
and then that can give you some ideas on
on where else to look
um the next thing we want to talk about
is that network
who who can we go out to again we've
done a lot of
you know full webinars on networking but
just as a
very basic reconnecting with former
classmates and colleagues
in person online if obviously online and
in person if possible and seeing if you
can
reach out and have some conversations
again joining those online groups and
discussions
when people are meeting in person again
there's meetups and event rights and
possibly alumni events and
you know i know a lot of people who have
found opportunities during
the pandemic and during covid this uh
over the past six months
and one of the ways is there's there's
so much
content and webinars just like today
that are happening
every day you could you could probably
attend something for free
that's out there and because there is so
much right now what i found is there's a
lot of
like today there's a small group of you
on that
makes it easier to connect with people
talk to people
every tuesday um this is tuesday today
but this morning
uh tuesday mornings we at 11 a.m central
time
9 a.m pacific time we haven't a drop in
coaching session which is there's
usually at least
there's always one coach usually even
maybe two or three of us
where we address questions that are
coming up and it's a great time to have
some open conversation with the coaches
and to network with some udacity
students as well
so finding those and being active and
being present
so now we need to prepare to address the
gap so
let's all assume we've got been sitting
here we've thought oh gosh here i am
i've been out of the workforce for three
years five years whatever it is
you need to prepare to address it people
start preparing all these interview
questions
and then you sit back and say what are
you going to do and they say what have
you done the last three years
and you really have to think about this
and prepare because
first you need to believe in yourself so
that others can too
and you have to have the strategy to
discuss the gap
so we're going to give you a little
three-step
process to help you address the gap
it's state it fill it and then close it
so you're going to state the gap why
were you unemployed and that can be as
simple as
i was i took medical leave the past
three years
boom that's all you need to talk about
you don't need to give them big
descriptions
or the y's or the house it's just it was
medical leave personal leave whatever it
was then you fill the gap i want you to
think about some things you've done
during the gap and again
it's perfectly normal that during a gap
especially if it was quite long
that you did very little for maybe weeks
or months at a time
but thinking about there were probably
moments there were probably
special projects something you
volunteered on think about what you did
some of the good things you did in that
gap to keep you mentally sharp
to keep you close to your industry or
maybe even just building different
skills
uh maybe of some volunteer work that you
did
then talk about closing the gap and what
you want to do now
so let's look at each of those
so remember stated why were you
unemployed you want to be honest
you want to be direct but you want to
keep it concise again i
i know like i talked about the black
cloud up there that people feel like
when they have something that's a
negative or that's weighting them down
it's really normal to talk too much
about it
and to feel like you have to explain it
and then re-explain it and justify it
and then it puts way too much focus on
it whether that's a
if you're talking about a weakness or
you're talking about a gap
that's really normal that happens to
people
so you want to make sure it doesn't
happen to you and this is why you want
to think how do i say it
one sentence what was that gap
and the next is to fill it again what
did you do and you can
break it down to a few different
categories to think about it and if you
are in your gap right now
and you don't plan on looking soon or
going back soon
think about some of the things you can
do and i know a lot of people who take a
gap let's say it's five years and
the first three and a half years they
really felt like they removed themselves
from their professional world
and then they're like okay i'm going to
want to go back to work
maybe the next year or so so i need to
get moving on some things what should i
do
so professional activities freelancing
projects
events meetings workshops writing
blogging anything in that professional
realm that you can think of
continuing education things like the
udacity course
free courses that are online maybe in
some soft skills or
hearing some free content that's from
people in your industry
other activities could be community
involvement maybe
you did maybe you were active in your
child's school
maybe with your religious organization
or some community events
did you do any mentoring did you help
other people and think about those
different activities you might have done
did you help someone with their business
on the side even if it was very
casually if you did some kind of
very casual even friendly type of
consulting
write those things down think about what
you did and i think
most people i think are surprised when
they start realizing how much they did
do
of course usually not up to the extent
of a full-time job
but some really valuable interesting
work that might have some transferable
skills
and give you something to talk about to
show
that you were you had some productivity
during this time
and and just kind of let me go back to
that for one second you don't need to
tell them
what you did for the whole three year
period your point is to highlight
the most important handful of things
that you did
that you can talk about some of the work
and then close it how do you what do you
want to do now how do you show that
enthusiasm about relaunching your career
that commitment in going back to work
and to be clear about the work you want
to do and this is really where you give
someone the confidence
that you're ready you're excited about
it and you're going to be that fearless
learner that wants to get in there and
get back in the game
and i think once you can
go through these steps and think about
excuse me once you can go through these
steps and and
answer this question with confidence
then you're going to be
that big step closer to positioning
yourself
for the jobs that you want to have
i'm going to just pause here for a
second
and ask if there are any questions
and i want you to think about the
benefits that you might have
gained by having a gap
maybe there was something that you
realize that a course you took
something you did like thinking about
how you filled
that gap and and some of the things that
maybe you want to share
that you did during that time
so any ideas on first questions any
questions that you might have at this
stage
to think about the gap talking about the
gap
and does anyone want to share some of
the benefits they think they gained
by having the gap some people feel like
it gave them a time to reflect
and look at what they really want to do
some people it's personal they get to
spend more time with their kids and that
made that gap
and that fulfilling part of their life
it made it all worth it
and those are some things to think about
and and doug with your
obviously recovering and getting your
health back is a really important thing
and then well for me it's
not only the physical but also
just like you said reflecting about
you know what do i really want
and uh i'm not just doing it for the
money anymore it's just more
or prestige i'm just doing it for myself
right and
that's the reason i'm i just want to go
back to just being a programmer i just
realized you know
that's just where i feel happier you
know
and i can have some time
by myself as opposed to always being
with people
which i found out it drains me over a
long period of time
well and that's that's another thing
when they talk about
employers liking and appreciating the
maturity
of the mature more mature employees is
that
we often uh it takes us a lot a lot of
us
some time to figure out what it is we
want to do and where we're happiest
in our careers and the type of job we
want so
when we figured that out you know i
think that makes for a really great
employee to say hey doug knows exactly
kind of where he wants to fit in he
knows what makes him happy and he knows
what kind of position
is going to suit him best so there's not
many question marks left for us
so thanks for sharing any other thoughts
or questions here
uh just to review some of the do's and
don'ts as you approach
the going heading back one is to of
course again
make sure you address the gap don't try
to hide it to
uh find a way to finagle dates and and
make it like it wasn't really there i
think that that
that makes that black cloud loom a
little harder and it's better to be
very open transparent remember you don't
have to go into a lot of detail
next is to be clear with your goals you
know it sounds like doug knows
very he's quite clear on what he wants
to do if you're not that clear that's
okay but at least be clear that
i'm ready to go back to work this is
what i'm willing to commit to
and and having that enthusiasm
making sure you can articulate your
message with confidence go through that
three-step process write it out what do
you want to say what do you want to
point out that you've done
how do you want to talk about what you
want to do in the future and having that
future focus
again having that enthusiasm and finding
a support network as you're talking to
people about
being on the market uh think about who
are the
who are the key people in your inner
circle that
are going to be really good to help you
now that might not be your
personal inner circle your very close
friends and family it might be some
former business colleagues uh something
someone that used to work with a lot who
you respect and
they can give you feedback and give you
input
and think about having that support
network that you can
reach out to and rely on and and even
you know having regular conversations
with sometimes people like to have
if you don't have a coach you work with
even just an accountability type of
partner friend that says
you know hey i'm going to start looking
for a job i'm going to get back
out there i'd love to just could we
check in with each other can i come back
to you every thursday at 3 o'clock and
tell you what i've done this week
let you know the progress i've made and
get some input and feedback from you
and again being that fearless learner
that i loved that term that carol used
when she talked about that and i think
that's really important
especially if the longer our break has
been that we need to
show that enthusiasm and that
willingness to just learn as much as we
can and
jump back in the game and it's okay to
ask for help
from your from your network from that
support network from different friends
a lot of people get back to work by
reaching out to former colleagues that
they worked with
they worked for they managed and those
are you know if you were a good manager
and you have people who liked working
for you
and you're and you are reaching out to
them to say hey
i'm you know i'm back in the game i want
to look for something
they're very likely to help you so don't
be afraid to reach out
what you don't want to do again you
don't want to dodge the question or
dwell on it
it's really easy to do to give too much
information and dwell on that gap and
then it that will always hold you back
always
so remember you state it quickly then
you really talk you get future focused
you talk about the great things you've
done on that break
some of those transferable skills
different projects and then you
get really future focused you don't want
to discuss it with uncertainty i've
worked with a lot of people who
really aren't sure they're ready to go
back to work and and that's okay to tell
your career coach and to tell your
friends if you're not sure
that's okay and those insecurities but
when you get ready to go
interview you don't want to let that
uncertainty and those insecurities come
through it's really important at that
stage to
to show your commitment and your
enthusiasm
some additional resources that we can
share with you
these are the top i relaunch
is primarily a lot focused on women
going back to work after a break
but they're they do have programs that
are open to others uh the mom project
also
i think that the top three
i think a lot of these i would say were
originally
started for women that were coming back
to work
but most of them now are really open to
men and women as more men have taken
breaks whether medical or paternal leave
so i think in in any case
even if it's not like you're going to
fit into one of their programs
it's there's many of these sites have
really great resources where you can
learn about interviewing and going back
to work and um
picking up different skills in terms of
the job search
this is the slide that carol shared with
us when we had our session a couple
weeks ago
they are having and you can go on their
website and get a lot more information
but just to they essentially
when it's when there's not a pandemic
they have a few
workshops and almost like career fairs
and workshops together
and they have a couple in different
locations they're in person
this time they are going to be both are
virtual
and for one price you get access to the
october and november
and there will be
coaching panels there will be resources
and tools to help you with the job
search
interviewing strategies and
live there's actually you get they have
a lot of big sponsors and then you have
access to talk to some of those people
so i don't know the exact sales pitch
quite specifically enough but i know
enough to know that
i think it's a great opportunity and for
the price
unfortunately that early bird price is
over
but even at 179 the regular price i
think it's going to be a really really
great
space with ireland most of their
sponsors are
in tech so
um or i should say the technical
positions people with technical
backgrounds are where a lot of the
positions
come from so it's perfect for udacity
students
in the in the tech sector
and that is our content for today so
again today was all about kind of
following up we had had some questions
that were outstanding
from the last group and i think a few of
you are on here that i see from last
time
and we wanted to follow make sure we
kind of finished the conversation i know
our fireside chat was
was quick and fast and we didn't have
time for tons of questions
so we wanted to be able to readdress it
and then
open it up for more questions again
today
so at this stage i'm going to stop
sharing my screen
and we'll just go into an open q a
session
and i will go ahead and i'm going to
stop the recording so for those of you
watching delayed thank you for being
tuning in and i will look forward to
hopefully seeing some of you live in one
of our further sessions but i'll stop
the recording and then we'll just have
time for a
q a here for who's here live thanks